President Joe Biden was up in
Connecticut over the weekend for a gun
control Summit at the University of
Hartford where the president focused his
remarks on a prayer for the long life of
a dead English monarch and if you can
see the camera they can see you and it's
the least consequential part of this
whole meeting for you I promise
all right God Save the Queen man
[Applause]
and then the best part is he he just
points he goes am I supposed to go off
this way am I and I and as he does that
the crowd there they go
God Save the Queen man
on the one hand probably the most
conservative and dignified thing Joe
Biden has ever said a little bit late
didn't didn't totally make sense in the
middle of Connecticut nine months after
Queen Elizabeth died
back I kind of like I know it's better
than a lot of things the guys said even
Joe Biden's professional Spin Doctors
can't make sense of it perhaps Biden
confused New England with old England
perhaps Joe Biden was referring to drag
queens it was a little bit of a pride
month valedictory nah not quite not
quite convincing the only explanation is
the one that we've all known for a long
time which is that Joe Biden
who was never The Brightest Bulb in the
pack
is fading even further
a couple fries short of a Happy Meal few
cans short of a six-pack know what I'm
saying catch my drift the lights are on
but no one's home and we all know it but
the ruling class can't do very much
about it Joe Biden is the incumbent
he's almost certainly the Democrat
nominee for president in 2024. so if the
Democrats want to hang on to power
they're going to have to rig the
election which is exactly what they are
currently doing I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
there's the race right now which is
basically Trump versus Biden those are
the guys who are leading by a lot in the
race
but there's a Shadow race going on too
which is the number two guy in both
parties DeSantis going after Gavin
Newsom which we'll get to in just a
second what that means for the dynamic
of the race first though are they
rigging the election
we're we're now allowed to openly talk
about rigging the election even on
certain big Tech platforms that may have
banned me last week we're back we're
back for now uh but now you're allowed
to talk about that now that the 2020
election is over and the Democrats got
away with it you're allowed to openly
even on these platforms not just on
daily wire plus where I had previously
been talking about this but but openly
on big Tech you're allowed to say what
we all know which is that the Democrats
rigged the last election by changing all
of the voting rules in the weeks and
months before the election took place
and they changed those rules in a way
that was advantageous to Democrats
and which hurt Republicans so how are
they rigging the election this time not
not just by changing the voting rules in
some cases some of the rules have
changed back but broadly the Democrats
have just kept that Victory widespread
mail-in ballots they've kept the uh
changing of rules such that it even
contradicts the state constitutions as
we see in Pennsylvania uh ballot
harvesting all the rest of it how are
they changing at this time how are they
rigging it this time they're rigging it
by
indicting the chief political rival
and they're indicting him in New York
and they're indicting him on federal
charges in Miami and they're going after
him in all sorts of ways there were
there were civil actions coming up they
are just going to try to Pummel this guy
with the law such that they can either
bury his campaign or literally put him
into prison and and it's not just my
opinion that this is election
interference this is the opinion of most
Americans
even if it were just my opinion I think
that's a good enough reason to you know
take it seriously but according to a
Harvard Harris poll most people believe
that the Trump indictments constitute
election interference
of registered voter respondents 55 say
the indictment is politically motivated
versus only 45 percent who find the
indictment valid which is an interesting
way of phrasing the question because the
indictment could be valid and
politically motivated
and it could be
not politically motivated but also
invalid not not legally serious but here
you've got a clear majority of people
who say it's politically motivated and a
clear minority of people who say that
it's it's
valid similarly 56 percent of the
participants categorize the indictment
as interference by the Department of
Justice in the 2024 elections only 44
see this as a fair application of the
law so Americans know what's up it's not
just the Republicans it's not just the
conservatives even Democrats a lot of
Democrats fair-minded Democrats
understand this is Joe Biden wielding
his political power to rig the game
against the leader of the political
opposition which is something that we
have never seen anywhere near this scale
in American history deeply corrupt a
major shift in our political order even
the Democrats are admitting it
so you know that you can rely on Mitt
Romney to defend it you know when
something is so clear it's so obviously
favoring the liberal establishment you
know that you can rely on Liberal
Republicans such as Mitt Romney to
defend the uniparty swampy establishment
strategy
I'm angry
um the country is going to go through
tumult as a result of one thing
president Trump didn't turn over
military documents when he was asked to
do so
all he had to do was hand him in
I'm sure his counsel told him hand the
documents in particularly when the
subpoena came but for some reason he
decided not to he held on to them why
that's the question why is the country
going to have to go through all this
angst and timel why do you just turn the
documents in
I am angry I'm angry I I don't even want
to do my Romney impression because it's
not good enough and I end up just
sounding like Reagan and I don't want to
compare Mitt Romney to Ronald Reagan I
said I am angry I'm angry at Trump
I'm angry at the Republicans I'm angry
at the conservatives you can always rely
on Mitt Romney and the Republicans like
Mitt Romney to punch right
They Don't Really punch left
BLM is burning the country down Mitt
Romney is going to be out there marching
with BLM
Donald Trump is selectively prosecuted
for an alleged crime that many of his
predecessors potentially all of his
predecessors but at the very least many
of his predecessors
and his successor Joe Biden all
committed
but it's Trump's fault
of course this is preposterous
if if
virtually every modern president has
committed this one crime
and Donald Trump is the only one who's
prosecuted for it then the thing that
changed here is not the presidents or
what the presidents are doing the thing
that changed is the doj the thing that
changed is the prosecutors the person
who deserves the blame is the top
prosecutor in the country and his boss
Joe Biden
Romney won't say that
because the debate that we're seeing in
our country increasingly is not between
Republican and Democrat the debate
seeing our country is increasingly not
between leftist and conservative the
debate in our country is as Patrick
denane writes in his new quite good book
uh regime change this conservative
writer Patrick Denine says that the the
big divide now is between the many and
the few the people and what we call the
uni party the elite Democrats
and the elite Republicans joining
together this is how you're getting talk
of say
a Donald Trump
may be picking
Democrat Bobby Kennedy Jr as his running
mate how honor what how on Earth does
Trump the I guess Conservative
Republican share a significant amount of
voters people who admire
Bobby Kennedy that's so Str how is that
because that old political divide is
breaking down to something a little bit
more basic and a little bit more
populist and as our political order
breaks down you got to probably check
out Birch gold right now text Knowles to
98 98 98 Congress once again has allowed
itself to be pushed into appeasing the
administration and raising the debt
ceiling for the 79th time Paving the way
for continued Reckless spending and
further devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold these are the guys I trust
to get your gold from thousands of other
concerned Savers do as well Birch gold
will help you convert an existing Ira or
401K into an IRA in Gold you don't have
to pay a penny out of pocket and you can
be like me
have your Birch gold ready to go when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers text null scanner wlas to 98
98.98 get your free info kit on gold
text Knowles to 98 98 98. speaking of
the unit party the Nevada Republican
governor
Joe Lombardo just signed a bill into law
that will force insurance companies to
pay for transgender procedures
not even just transiting the adults this
bill is going to force companies to pay
to trans the kids that is the Republican
governor of Nevada
this comes as nearly 20 states have
signed laws to ban tranzing the kids
but the GOP in Nevada they're going to
promote Transit the kids the battle is
so much harder than a lot of us realize
because we focus our iron Joe Biden or
Barack Obama or I don't know AOC some
big Libs we are not merely fighting
those liberal Democrats we are also
fighting against the squishy Liberal
Republicans
leftists don't have that same battle
because the leftists and the liberal
establishment have a lot more overlap
than the conservatives and the liberal
establishment have and so we are
fighting a seriously uphill battle the
only Silver Lining here
is
from a political standpoint well one the
truth is on our side God is on our side
but from a political standpoint
especially in this Fallen world that is
ruled by the Prince of Darkness for at
the moment the only real political
Silver Lining that we've got
is that the people are on our side as
well
now that might not matter because the
people have a decreasing say in how the
government is run but the people are
pretty clearly on our side and they're
moving more so not just the people
saying hey we don't think you should
trans the kids not even just the people
trans really anybody the people going
even further there's a new
survey out this is from Gallup
gallup's new uh survey numbers show that
support for same-sex relations not just
the T
not just the TQ or the transiting the
little kids but the LGB part
has declined sharply
last year
71 of U.S adults said gay or lesbian
relations are morally acceptable that
number has fallen back this year to 64
so that's a seven percentage Point drop
it's a major 10 drop in the the number
of Americans saying that any kind of
same-sex sexual relations are even
morally acceptable
last time we saw that number was in
2019.
so we've Fallen back four years and
obviously there's a long way to go to
get to any place where you might say
that this is a major conservative or
right-wing Force but the shift is pretty
dramatic
the the main reason here is because of
Republicans Republicans who had
previously been embracing the rainbow
over the last decade or so have turned
against the rainbow flag again 56
percent of Republicans said that
same-sex relations were acceptable last
year that figure has dropped to 41
percent this past year 15 Point drop
and uh vast majority of Democrats say
it's morally acceptable a majority of
Independents say it as well so for
Republicans this is the lowest amount of
same-sex relationship support since
2014. expect that decline to keep up
expect that at least for the next year
or two
who knows depending on how the 2024
election shapes up if the Democrats
succeed at rigging the election then you
might see the Republican Party swing
back in a more liberal Direction but for
right now the GOP is headed in a more
conservative Direction and you're going
to see that number keep up and you might
say wait a second what what does
same-sex relations have to do with
transiting the kids yes we don't want
men going into the girls room yes we
don't want men taking away women's
trophies competing against women in
sports yeah that part's gone crazy but
why are people now reacting against
same-sex relations
well because they're all of a piece
they're all of that initialism LGBT
they're all represented by the rainbow
flag they all derive from the same
premises of the sexual Revolution and
because the sexual revolutionaries just
took it a little bit too far and because
they took it too far
because they took their ideas to their
logical conclusions this is now causing
thoughtful conservatives to re-evaluate
the premises that they began with
the way we got transgenderism I've said
it before I said it in my CPAC speech
it's caused a lot of consternation we
don't need to go too in depth into it is
that the way we got transgenderism is we
began with the premise that men and
women are basically the same
this was the premise of the feminists it
was adopted by the sexual
revolutionaries that gave us the kind of
Village People stuff then that premise
led inexorably to the redefinition of
marriage because if men and women are
exactly the same then the union of two
men has to be the same thing as the
union of a man and a woman has to be the
same thing as the union of two women and
if men and women are basically the same
then it's not a very far leap to say
that a man can become a woman or
socially identify as a woman or
practically just be a woman in public
life and vice versa that's how we got
there now that people know that it's
[Music]
I love
it that's causing people to reevaluate
all the first stuff and it's a reminder
of advice from Cardinal Manning which is
that there is a day to come that will
reverse The Confident judgments of men
you had all sorts of uniparty
establishments squishy Republican DC
swamp types who for years said the GOP
has to ditch the social issues this
isn't popular the American people don't
like it we've all just got to run and
embrace whatever the next liberal fad is
and we just focus on cutting taxes and
it's going to win us elections and that
isn't true the American people are
moving in a decidedly socially
conservative Direction it's just gone
too far and so you're going to see
you're going to see a big reaction to
that
there is an argument to be made for
tolerating the sexual eccentricity as a
Prudential matter
people don't want to send the morality
police door to door to go into people's
bedrooms and say hey what are you doing
in there you got any whips and chains in
here we're going to confiscate those
okay nobody is really arguing for that
but but the
the argument would be the the best
argument you could make for that
would be as a matter of prudence
a toleration that comes from the
acknowledgment that this is a fallen
world and people do all sorts of weird
and wacky things and there's diversity
and eccentricity in life and so we're
just going to look the other way
sometimes when people do kind of weird
stuff
what the sexual revolutionaries did what
the Liberals did is they insisted on on
taking the Prudential Toleration that
that Americans had long had for
diversity and eccentricity and deviance
and they would they insisted that we now
redefine all of those things as
positively good as wonderful as a human
right
for the vast majority of American
History weird sexual behavior was
illegal and illegal pretty much
everywhere and then during the mid-2000s
justices on the Supreme Court decided
that there's a constitutional right to
weird sex stuff where is that I don't
know I guess James Madison probably
wrote it in invisible ink and then the
justices in the mid-2000s discovered
that I don't know they had their decoder
liquid and they found out that there's
this right to weird sex stuff in the
Constitution and then a decade later
they discovered the Romantic poet
Anthony Kennedy and the Supreme Court
discovered that secretly there was a
right that redefined marriage to be not
what it had always been for all of human
history everywhere but this new thing
which involves the the rainbow flag and
they Define this as a positive right and
the the problem for these
revolutionaries there is yes they got a
political win yes they established their
new sexual mores in the law but everyone
knows it's BS nobody seriously thinks
this stuff is like great okay you might
say no people have certain weaknesses
and certain desires and we're just going
to kind of like Let It Go and look the
other way but obviously it's not normal
it's not the center of human life
there's one relationship that that is so
profound and beautiful and natural and
and
reflect something beyond our purely
natural understanding
which is the ability to procreate and
create human life
in
only one kind of relationship can do
that
and as a as a matter of even fine-tuning
that relationship we know that for the
purpose of flourishing for not only the
creation of a child but the raising of
that child the development of that child
the best relationship for that is the
union of a husband and a wife in
marriage which is for not only the good
of this passage but the sake of the
generation and the education of children
and we all know that's true and a bunch
of lives on the Supreme Court can deny
it and a bunch of activists can scream
about it in front of the court and
corporations can can force and lie about
it onto every product including our beer
cans but we all know that that is true
and so we're happy to be tolerant nice
accepting people and open-minded and
practical and realistic but you can't
make us lie okay you've got it the if
the Liberals just wouldn't hold a gun to
our heads and just make us lie all the
time and say if you don't lie we're
going to get you fired from your job
we're gonna get you kicked off of
YouTube we're gonna get you kicked out
of school we're gonna we're gonna
de-platform you because that's so
offensive to so many people that the
pendulum is swinging back in the other
direction
now something that I can tell you is not
a lie is completely 100 true you can
take it to the bank is have delicious
good ranchers meat is right now go to
goodranchers.com use code Knolls as our
great Nations birthday approaches we are
coming together as proud Americans and
savoring the delicious Taste of
home-grown American-made meat our
friends at good Ranchers have the best
Quality Meats you've ever tasted and
they only sell meat that was raised here
in the U.S of a from now until
Independence Day good ranchers will be
offering the best deals to give you
freedom from the meat aisle from rib
eyes New York strips all natural Burgers
to the most delicious chicken you could
ever want good ranchers has something
for everyone plus right now you will get
30 bucks off with code Knowles kwles at
goodranchers.com if you are looking for
a way to wow your family during your
fourth of July Gathering check out their
website recipe of the Texas style
chopped patty melt it is so freaking
good they have the best the market the
prices are lower than everybody's
they're just phenomenal okay what are
you waiting for let the aroma of
American-made meat fill the air
bringing Joy unity and delectable
flavors to your celebrations
goodranches.com use code Knowles for 30
bucks off any box Canada w-l-e-s that's
the code goodranches.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
folks have you tried the Precision 5
Jeremy's razor have you tried it well
you better now you can get one handle
plus one blade cartridge kit for the low
low cost of 14.99 Jeremy's lowest cost
for a Razor and only for a limited time
it is crafted with a luxurious tungsten
handle five welded steel blades and a
flip back trimmer for a close smooth
shave around hair lines and hard to
reach places but remember the Precision
5 is no ordinary razor it's a sword in
the battle for beliefs it's a banner to
wave into a new economy
it's a Precision instrument to force
woke companies to earn back your dollar
and stop denigrating your beliefs
it's also still a razor it will give you
a great shave the Precision Thrive is
starting at 14.99 with a price so low it
has never been easier to stop giving
your money to what corporations than
hate your guts join Over 125 000 men who
have ditched their woke razors and
switched to Jeremy's never been a better
time or Price go to Jeremy's razors.com
today
speaking of Bud Light
Bud Light has just yet again issued a
major statement
to dig the hole even deeper Bud Light
crater they've now lost their position
as the number one beer in America they
lost it to Modelo Especial I love that
Modelo is a very Latin American
something beer is now the number one
beer in America I just think that is
awesome love it Bud Light is number two
Bud Light trying to dig themselves out
but they know that they can't apologize
because their ESG woke corporate
overlords pushing a radical liberal
agenda the people who control the money
the people who control the social
platforms they're saying you've got to
embrace the rainbow flag but but Bud
light's customers the people hate the
rainbow flag and they hate having
transvestitism on their beer can so
they're caught between a rock and a hard
place and they issued another statement
that is attempting to satisfy everyone
and pleases exactly nobody they say we
recognize it over the last two months
the discussion surrounding our company
in Bud Light has moved away from beer
and this has impacted our customers our
business partners and our employees
we're a beer company and beer is for
everyone
no the problem is that your beer is not
for everyone your beer is not for me
it's not for the construction worker
it's not for the frat boy it's not for
your ordinary customer base that you
denigrated it's not
you're you're you are signaling to your
customer base that your beer is no
longer for them and your customers are
signaling to you much more clearly with
their wallet
that that your beer is no longer for
them either it's not for everyone a
friend to all is a friend to none okay
you can have the best interests of
everyone at heart
you can try to pursue the common good
and flourishing for everybody but if you
just try to appease everybody
and and try to embrace mutually
contradictory ideas and desires you're
not going to please everybody you're
going to please nobody
he said that the company's announcing
three important actions as they continue
to move the business forward first
we're investing to protect the jobs of
our Frontline employees
that's that doesn't sound like moving
the business forward that sounds like
trying to stop the hemorrhaging that's
going on in your business right now
Frontline employees like they're First
Responders or something like that we're
going to try to we're going to try to
protect the jobs of them why because
your company is cratering these you're
screwing up because you are killing the
number one beer in America that's why
you have to do that's a defensive action
two we are providing financial
assistance to our independent
wholesalers to help them support their
employees right also you're just trying
to stop the bleeding this is a defensive
action because no one wants your product
anymore and then three
they say our summer advertising launches
next week you look forward to Bud Light
reinforcing what you've always loved
about our brand and it's easy to drink
and easy to enjoy as we move forward
we'll focus on what we do best Brewing
great beer and earning our place in
moments that matter to you you want to
earn your place apologize and say that
you don't believe all the liberal
claptrap that you were embracing with
your Dylan Mulvaney campaign that's how
you do it that's how you earn the place
back until you do that we're not buying
your beer anymore and your beer is going
to continue to tank these guys are
screwed okay it I realized it over this
weekend coincidentally I was in the same
town as Joe Biden this weekend sleepy
little Hartford Connecticut I landed at
the Hartford airport and there was a lot
of traffic I said there's some traffic
around here and it's because Joe Biden
was in town so I was I was in the town
for the God Save the Queen remark
coincidentally and then I went to my
cousin's wedding
in Connecticut and I realized
the the depth of Bud light's problems
because the Knowles family
has a wide spectrum of political views
the Knowles family I think is pretty
representative of America lots of
a handful of you know hardcore
conservatives handful of Hardcore
liberals lots of people kind of in the
middle center right center left and
one of the main jokes of the weekend
was over who was going to drink a Bud
Light
there was like one case of Bud Light and
one of the coolers at this wedding and
our my liberal relatives and my
conservative relatives were all joking
about it they said oh that's the woke
test oh yeah is anyone gonna actually go
I want to see if anyone drinks that beer
at one point a cousin one of my cousins
he says hey Michael don't worry I got
you beer I think this is going to be
your favorite beer and I and as a Bud
Light you know and then I pop it open
and pretend that it turned me gay and
then everybody laughs and that's the J
people are doing this at bars now it's a
meme man
and then by the way I wouldn't finish
the beer my another more liberal cousin
of mine comes over says hey I'll I'll
finish the I know you can't drink that I
don't really want it but whatever I'll
drink it's okay
they're screwed it when when your
company becomes a punch line
you know that uh things are not in the
right direction for you
okay and
Bud Light is is a good stand-in for the
whole movement
the
the rainbow flag movement wasn't always
a punch line it didn't always get PR
that was this bad
the rainbow flag movement for a long
time got really really good PR for a
long time it was Will and Grace it was
really Chic and Cosmopolitan and
sophisticated and even straight guys
wanted to seem like gay guys they
remember the the metrosexual movement of
the 2000s where you had guys who were
normal you know desired women did not
desire men but they would kind of dress
up like they were a little light in the
loafers and they would do this not just
because they were European this happened
even in America
it got really good PR now the rainbow
flag stands for Creeps in libraries
talking to little kids and putting porn
in elementary schools stands for people
chopping their bodies up sterilizing
themselves looking ghastly
that's what it has become
Bud Light is reflecting that you want to
talk about jokes this is actually the
saddest new story I've read over the
weekend there were a number of sad ones
adults
are now
for their Recreation going to bouncy
castles
I saw this story
in in the Wall Street Journal Wall
Street Journal is not a sensationalist
tabloid paper far from it very stable
stayed establishment paper
the new Night Out adults-only bouncy
houses
grown-ups try to rekindle a childhood
Pastime this time with Achy muscles that
hurt my back
adults are discovering that jumping in
bouncy houses a childhood Pastime is not
the same when you're older and less
nimble
grown-ups aren't just hopping with their
kids but are increasingly bouncing
around with other full-grown humans
adults are renting bouncy houses for
weddings birthdays and Company parties
some are having as much fun as
youngsters occasionally helped by
pre-bounce booze adults don't bounce
back the way they used to and then it
talks about how they you know their
backsworth or something afterward
this is just the latest iteration of a
trend that we saw through McDonald's
where McDonald's was was going to sell
happy meals for adults kids meals that
were not for kids that are for adults
the trend of adults
going regularly without kids to
Children's theme parks
that why are adults doing this adults
are doing this
because they don't have kids
there are some right-wingers and
conservatives who are just going to make
fun of these adults say these adults are
losers they're they they're never grew
up they're overgrown children this is
pathetic they're going to mock them for
wanting to do these things that's
my take on it actually
my take is that these adults have
perfectly normal nostalgia
perfectly normal desires to have fun
there are other ways to have fun than
just like going to a bar or something
like that so I recognize their other
being a kid is kind of fun and adults
remember that
but this is the wrong way to follow
those desires and that inclination
the right way to follow those Desires in
that inclination is to have kids
this one of the secret little joys of
having kids is you get to do kid things
again and kid things are fun
it's fun to go throw a ball around in a
park it's fun to like wrestle on the
floor and play with cars and stuff it's
fun to go ride bikes around the
neighborhood it's fun to go to bouncy
castles and eat Happy Meals and that is
a fun thing to do
but it's
weird if you do it without kids not
everyone gets to have kids some people
suffer infertility you can do it with
your nieces and nephews you can do it in
your community and go kind of rough ass
with the kids okay yeah that's kind of
that isn't that fun but if you do it
as an adult
you it's sad
because you
you haven't grown up
it's just you can't you actually can't
go back in time this is the whole
premise I've said it before in this show
this is the premise of that Kenny
Loggins song the back and Pooh Corner to
help me if you can I've got to get back
it's this whole song about how this kid
is graduating high school and he's out
in the 100 Acre Wood with Winnie the
Pooh but he can't he can't get back he
doesn't
he wants to go get back and hang out
with his friends uh Eeyore and Winnie
the Pooh and
I don't really remember the Winnie the
Pooh story that much because because I'm
an adult but
he wants to go back and he realizes he
can't because he's become an adult and
that is now closed off to him but the
final verse of the song
is that he looks into his son's crib and
he sees that his son has a little Winnie
the Pooh doll or a Tigger doll or
something like that and he says oh I I'm
I'm back now I get to go back to Pooh
Corner now but it's through this
different lens in a different place and
now I am in a new stage of life and I'm
passing this on to the next Generation
but we don't have a sense of the future
in our country anymore we don't have
hope for the future we don't have a
sense of responsibility toward the
future that's why we don't really get
married we don't really have kids and
The Inheritance that we leave to the
kids that we do have is a mountain of
debt
that is a political problem not just
from the libs
who are the drivers of a lot of the
sexual dysfunction but that's a problem
for the conservatives who are who are
the drivers of some of the economic
dysfunction and that the
economic dysfunction that's led to a
breakdown in Social solidarity and an
idea that we have a great responsibility
both to our ancestors and to the Future
that comes after us all encapsulated in
a big bouncy house that a lot of
overgrown children are are hopping
around and they're hurting their backs
they're hurting their backs because
they're not meant to be there
they're meant to be helping the Next
Generation and getting to relive some of
their memories a little bit
in conjunction with them now speaking of
people throwing their weight around
big news story in the presidential race
I've predicted you know look you know I
hate to say I told you some we're seeing
some of my some of my predictions have
been coming through recently and there's
one prediction I have that's very
unpopular with a lot of you
and but I've stuck to it because I can't
lie to you I can't lie for big Tech I
can't lie for the Applause of the crowds
I'm just going to tell you what I think
and one thing I've said is that I have
felt that Chris Christie could have a
real moment in this presidential race
and everyone laughed at me and I said I
think run the rink of a chrysosons a
croissants if you will and folks
it's happening
first though my favorite comment
yesterday is from ramp
oh I'm sorry my that's not my favorite
comic book yesterday my favorite
Advertiser that I have before my
favorite comment from yesterday is ramp
right now go to ramp.com are you looking
for a better way to simplify your
business finances across expenses vendor
payments and accounting if so ramp could
be a complete game changer for your
business ramp is a corporate card an
expense management software designed to
help you save time and money with ramp
you can issue cards to every employee
with limits and restrictions and
automate expense reporting so you can
stop wasting time at the end of every
month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to the time that you
will save each month on employee
expenses will allow you to close your
books eight times faster businesses that
use Ram save an average of 3.5 percent
within the first year ramp is easy to
use get started in less than 15 minutes
whether you have five employees or five
thousand right now get 250 dollars when
you join ramp go to ramp.com Knowles
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
apply
my favorite comment from yesterday is
Diane iser8255 who says followed you the
whole time on daily wire plus the
ungagged content was the best ever thank
you very much for those of you who stuck
it out I was banned for a week on
YouTube because I articulated basic
truths and so they took me off of
YouTube for a week
but I said look we always put our show
on daily wire plus and now we're putting
the show on Twitter as a backstop and
you can always get the show uncensored
on the RSS on Apple podcasts Spotify
wherever you you get your podcasts so I
refuse to censor myself
but it is a fact that on YouTube because
of the new YouTube rules
we just can't put all of that content
here so if you want the full show with
my fully articulated fleshed out
opinions where the editors don't go in
or the Publishers or the big Tech
platforms go in and take away certain
sentences you got to get that on daily
wire Plus Twitter at M Knowles show and
apple podcasts but I guess for right now
we're back on YouTube until they want to
take me off entirely not because they
can refute anything I'm saying not
because I'm anything I'm saying is
particularly egregious or anything like
it but because the Liberals are trying
to rig the 2024 election and they're
trying to rig the 2024 election through
a variety of means including through big
Tech censorship through obviously the
indictment of the political opposition
and they're doing it because the emperor
has no clothes and everybody knows it so
the only thing they can do is is try to
cheat
now
speaking of 2024
Chris Christie
surging in New Hampshire
by the way I don't want this to be
misconstrued I'm not saying I'm
supportive of a Chris Christie run I'm
not saying I want Chris Christie to be
the Republican nominee or the president
or anything like that I'm just telling
you what I see happening in my
nullstradamus crystal ball and what I
see is Chris Christie is surging
Trump is still Far and Away the leader
in the field
nationally and in New Hampshire
by country mile he's got 47 of the vote
Rhonda Santa says 13 of the vote and
then there's Christy
not so far behind number number three at
nine percent next highest is Mike Pence
at five Nikki Haley at three Vivek at
three Tim Scott at three
someone else at five so someone else is
actually doing better
than all those candidates below my pens
now that the wrinkle here
is that Chris Christie also tops the
never ever list
so there's there's another poll of
candidates that you would never under
any circumstances vote for and Chris
Christie's at the top of that list
I don't think that really matters I
think that's less a reflection of Chris
Christie and more of a reflection of our
current political order
because the never ever list the second
person on the never ever list is Mike
Pence and the third person is Trump but
Trump is Far and Away the biggest leader
in the field so what does that tell you
all that tells you is that the
electorate is getting more polarized
which you already knew and it tells you
that there's a civil war in the
Republican party and there are all sorts
of Republicans who don't really agree
with one another anymore and this is
true or today than it's been at any time
in my lifetime when you've got people in
the Republican Party who are socially
conservative don't really care all that
much about you know big government or
something they actually want to wield
the government for their political ends
as people like Trump that's people like
Ron DeSantis and then you've got still a
kind of holdover uh establishment quasi
libertarian you know just shrink the
government give all the money to
corporations you still got those people
in the GOP you still got the Chamber of
Commerce people in the GOP you've still
got the milk toast people in the GOP and
they just don't agree with one another
so yeah of course the base is going to
be is going to be divided here Chris
Christie if he's already in number three
in New Hampshire right now if something
should happen with the Rhonda Santa
campaign if DeSantis does not start
gaining ground and gaining ground
quickly if he continues to kind of
remain stagnant even lose a little bit
of ground Chris Christie could end up
number two in New Hampshire
who the hell knows Chris Christie could
be number one in New Hampshire for that
matter depending on how the indictments
go with Trump
Chris asants my friends
it might be upon us and I know everyone
is really
complaining about this GOP race so it's
a mess oh no we're going to lose to the
Dems and maybe maybe we will I think we
could lose to the Democrats even if
everything goes perfectly
but
this is politics guys the fact that
anyone is even seriously considering a
trump Kennedy ticket is so wild and
crazy I find it delightful if you don't
like that stuff you don't like politics
now
take Trump and Biden out of it for a
second take Chris Christie out of it too
for a second
there's another race which is Ron
DeSantis sniping at Gavin Newsom Gavin
Newsom sniping at Rhonda santis because
if Trump is not the nominee DeSantis
looks like he's going to take it and if
Biden for whatever reason is not the
nominee it looks like Gavin Newsom is
going to take it
here is Rhonda Santos's advice for Gavin
Newsom with all those problems he has a
real serious fixation on the State of
Florida I mean I think it's just bizarre
that he does that but what I would tell
what I would tell him is you know what
stop pussy-footing around are you gonna
are you gonna throw your hat in the ring
and challenge uh Joe are you gonna get
in and do it or are you just going to
sit on the sidelines and Chirp so why
don't you throw your hat in the ring and
then we'll go ahead and talk about what
what's happening so
good line glad to see that DeSantis is
attacking Gavin Newsom but of course
there is no reason for Gavin Newsom to
throw his hat in the ring right now
Gavin Newsom is not traveling all around
the country attacking Ron DeSantis
building a national base from building
the beginnings of a campaign in order to
convince voters to vote for him over Joe
Biden that is not how the Democrat Party
Works
it's not how incumbency really works and
it's really not how the Democrat Party
Works
there is not going to be some Insurgent
Newsome campaign against Joe Biden I
don't think anything could happen Biden
could fall off a stage and then maybe
there's more of an opportunity but I
think what's going on right now is that
Gavin Newsom is traveling over the
country taking the shots at Rhonda
Sanders building up the campaign in
order to convince Democrat Party Elites
that he is a viable alternative I think
the Democrat Party muckity mucks
the people who exert a lot more control
over the Democratic party than the
Republican Elites can exert over the
Republican Party
they're looking at Biden and they're
saying this guy is just not functioning
and he's saying God Save the Queen in
Hartford Connecticut at a gun control
rally and he's just he's really not
there
and he's got a lot of corruption
allegations against him and it just
doesn't he's just doesn't look good
he he was able to be the guy who took
over the presidency from Trump but we're
getting diminishing returns with this
guy wish we could replace him but dratz
there's no one to replace him with
the vice president
who is much younger arguably in better
control of her faculties is less
coherent than Joe Biden
much less politically talented than Joe
Biden and then who's the other guy Pete
butterjudge oh yeah mayor Pete there we
go he's the that's the Republican Savior
or the Democrat savior rather mayor Pete
this local mayor who's a really
brilliant careerist who got himself a
cabinet position and blew it you should
never even hear the name of the
transportation secretary but Pete
bootage keeps stepping at it we keep
having transportation catastrophes so
that's not working and the main thing
he's known for is taking a bunch of time
off of work to chest feed his baby or
whatever he was doing paternity leave
okay not viable
to quote Donald Trump Alfred E Newman is
not going to become the president of the
United States so they've been sticking
with Biden but Gavin Newsom despite his
record of failure in California on a
policy level is a pretty compelling
candidate he's Rich he's tall he's good
looking he's articulate
he comes from a gigantic state so he's
got a decent political base he survived
a recall effort
yeah he's pretty good that's not a bad
choice so if if
Newsom behind the scenes can persuade
the makini mucks in the party that he's
a real alternative I think men are going
to see many more people start to turn on
Joe Biden then maybe he throws his hat
in the race
as of right now it would be political
suicide for him to do it
even as Biden is slipping more and more
in case you missed it forget about the
uh God saving the queen remark Joe Biden
also wants to warn people about gun
trucks you know there's regular you got
the Good Humor truck
comes around gives ice cream out and
then you got the gun trucks in New York
and Philly
because a federally licensed gun dealer
is required by law to run background
checks on those he's selling a weapon to
and in most cities are down in
Philadelphia and New York areas I know
well like up here you'd see a truck pull
up pull to the curb and selling weapons
selling guns selling AR-15 selling
weapons
well guess what you do that now you go
to jail
yeah guess what if you drive that gun
truck up and up in Rehoboth Beach I'm
gonna sit Corn Pop on you man you take
that to you take that to the queen Jack
so he's obviously slipping but before
Newsom there was no serious alternative
now there is an alternative so when I
tell you look out maybe Chris Christie
is going to come from somewhere when I
tell you look out a trump Kennedy ticket
is not implausible when I tell you
look out
maybe Joe Biden's not the nominee
Anything could happen we are 18 months
away from this presidential election we
are living in unprecedented times we're
living through the First Federal
indictment of a former president of the
United States to say nothing of the fact
that he's the leader of the opposition
things are shifting in real time
conservatives especially but Americans
broadly are rapidly changing what they
believe the way that elections are
conducted is rapidly changing
we aren't we sometimes you're in periods
of stagnancy sometimes you're in pure
stagnation rather sometimes you're in
periods of intense change we are in the
latter and God saved the queen man is
probably not long for this political
world
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
and use code Knowles Canada wbles check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]